au sommaire une boucle vers la fenêtre
des mac par le bras patates et le
sentier du contrefort la curiosité de la
semaine balade dans les arbres à mach
aventure rendez-vous au mac sur la route
en direction de la fenêtre vous pourrez
vous garer au départ du sentier à côté
de cette vaste aire de pique nique du
plateau mon plaisir
pour cette randonnée facile de 4 km
prévoir de quoi vous protéger de la
pluie et une réserve d'eau
pour votre santé parcourez nos sentiers
bien entretenu et aménager une aire de
pique nique des mac est un lieu de
détente idéal pour les familles et un
point de départ vers plusieurs
randonnées incontournable de la zone
comme tous les endroits fréquentés n
échappe toutefois pas la présence
d'espèces exotiques envahissantes comme
ce raisin marron ou vert de tenthrèdes
rien
quand on a le raisin marron donc là est
partiellement attaqué par la fameuse
mouche bleue sac été introduite
justement pour lutter contre contre
cette espèce envahissante donc la mouche
ll va pondre sur c'est sur ces feuilles
et ce sont les petites larves après
qu'ils vont se nourrir de ce réseau donc
là on voit quelques traces de
d'attac par les défoliations par les
larves on peut supposer que d'ici d'ici
quelques mois ce raisin marron il sera
il sera peut être anéanti quoi
une petite descente permet de rejoindre
le bras patate cette ravine qui sépare
la plaine des mac de la plaine du bois
de nèfles était autrefois cultivées ce
qui a modifié la végétation originel
malgré la présence de quelques mao
emblématique de la forêt de bois de
couleur des eaux c'est ici le longose
aussi envahissant qui règne en maître
m
à mesure que l'on remonte la ravine les
petites falaises de chaque côté donne un
aspect confiné on va les suspendus comme
on en trouve plutôt métropole le bras
patata une histoire géologique
particulière qu'à l'époque où le cercle
de silence était encore comblé ou le
sommet devait culminer un peu plus haut
et donc là c'est elle existe un des
exutoires principal du cirque donc tous
les autres du cirque passer par cette
vallée et avec les phénomènes de
destruction de glissements terrain donc
cette cet exutoire a pris place sur
l'actuel bras de silence avec très peu
profonde parce que bon l'érosion n'a pas
eu assez de temps pour creuser
suffisamment cette vallée comme on peut
le voir sur surtout les exports des
cirques notamment le bras de cilaos
rivière des galets et puis le bras
rivière du mât
au bout du bras patate quand le temps le
permet le paysage de cilaos s'offre à
nous plus facile que la montée vers le
piton cabris juste au dessus cet
itinéraire permet d'apprécier la même
vue à moindre effort
la remontée vers la fenêtre est la seule
véritable difficulté de cette petite
boucle raide mais courte elle réserve
parfois de belles surprises comme cette
espèce endémique en fleurs
à la fenêtre il n'est pas rare de
croiser du monde le point de vue bien
aménagé est accessible en voiture une
autre option pour profiter de la vue
mais moins bénéfique pour la forme
pour redescendre le sentier du
contrefort évite de croiser la route
après la traversée du brame apoula
descente à flanc de falaise offre de
beaux points de vue sur toute la plaine
des mac et jusqu'à la mer
de retour sur la route forestière il ne
restera plus que quelques centaines de
mètres à parcourir pour retrouver la
voiture
alors ce qui a bien sûr ce sentier c'est
qu'on peut faire une boucle sur leur
demi-journée donc en famille ap les
enfants que quelques petits passages
délicats en montant le sur la fenêtre
depuis le bras patate et puis la petite
descente dans le contrefort jusqu'à la
route donc l'intérêt de passer par voie
patate c'est qu'on passe dans une vallée
qui est quand même assez méconnu du
grand public et puis dès qu'on est
arrivé au bout de cette vallée puis là
c'est la cerise sur le gâteau donc là
c'est le paysage de panoramas sur le sur
silence parce que j'ai un pas sur cette
randonnée se sont tous la présence
d'espèces exotiques envahissantes comme
elles ont causé le raisin marron donc on
a ça tout le long de cette vallée quoi
donc ça c'est assez dommage mais malgré
ça on a quand même des espèces qui
persistent comme les mao les bois de
couleurs assez imposant
des tonnes de bois et des kilomètres de
câbles suspendus dans une forêt de
cryptomerias des mac construit sur
mesure et en évolution constante et
parcours de mac aventure ouverte 1 2011
sur notre curiosité de la semaine un
parc aventure c'est un ensemble de
parcours où les gens vont évoluer de
manière autonome en gérant leur sécurité
et donc ils vont passer d'arbre en arbre
avec différents agrès différents types
de jeux ce qui m'a fait choisir de
m'installer dans une forêt de
cryptomerias à la réunion c'est l'un des
seuls arbres qui pourrait supporter un
parc aventure c'est des arbres qui vont
avoir tendance à pousser plus ou moins
comme une colonne donc relativement de
manière cylindrique c'est des arbres qui
ont une bonne élasticité et c'est des
arbres qui résiste bien aux cyclones
d'une manière générale un énorme travail
de menuiserie et l'essentiel se fait
dans les arbres on ya de la préparation
du coupage de rondins metulla justement
tout le ponçage tout ça se fait dans les
arbres les arbres sont vivants donc il
faut il faut sans cesse bert à
entretenir un desserré
ce qui m'a donné envie de créer ce parc
déjà moi je viens du parapente je suis
moniteur de parapente se met un
déséquilibre être être en l'herbe et
tout ça c'est des choses que j'aime bien
ouais et que j'aime bien faire découvrir